so I have a vector-valued function each
year when I say vector-valued it means
you give me a t it's a function of T and
so you give me a T I'm not just going to
give you a number I'm gonna give you a
vector and as we'll see you're gonna get
a two-dimensional vector you could view
this as the X component of the vector
and the Y component of the vector and
you you are probably familiar by now
that there's multiple notations for even
a two-dimensional vector for example you
could use what's often you viewed as
engineering notation here where the X
component is being multiplied by the
horizontal Communitech Terr so you might
see something like that where that's the
unit vector plus the Y component for T
to the fourth plus 2 T plus 1 is
multiplied by the vertical unit vector
so these are both representing the same
thing it just has a different notation
and sometimes you'll see a vector valued
functions with an arrow on top to make
it explicit that this is a vector valued
function sometimes we'll people you'll
just hear people say well let H be a
vector valued function and they might
not write that arrow on top so now that
we have that other way what we are
interested in is well let's find the
first and second derivatives of H with
respect to T so let's first take the
let's take the first derivative H prime
of T well as you'll see that's actually
quite straightforward you're just going
to take the respective components with
respect to take the derivative of the
respective components with respect to T
so the X component with respect to T if
you were to take the derivative so with
respect to T what are you going to get
well we're gonna use the power rule
right over here 5 times the negative 1
or times a negative you're gonna get
negative 5 times T to the 5 minus 1
power so T to the 4th power the
derivative with respect to T of negative
6 well that's just 0 so that's the rate
of change of the X component with
respect to T and now we go to the Y
component so we're gonna do the same
thing derivative with respect to T is
going to be and then once again we just
use the power rule 4 times 4 is 16 T to
the third power
of Tootsie is just too and then
derivative of a constant well that's
zero we've already seen that so there
you have it so this is the rate of
change of the X component with respect
to T this is the rate of change of the Y
component with respect to T and one way
to do it and you know vectors can
represent many many many different
things but the the type of a
two-dimensional vector like this you
could imagine this being H of T being a
position vector in two dimensions and
then if you're looking at the rate of
change of position with respect to time
well then this would be the velocity
vector and then if we were to take the
derivative of this with respect to time
well we're going to get the acceleration
vector so if we say H prime prime of T
what is that going to be equal to H
prime prime of T well we just apply the
power rule again so four times negative
5 is equal to negative 20 T to the 4
minus 1 so T to the third power and then
we have three times 16 is 48 T squared
and then the derivative of 2 is just
zero and so there you have it for any if
you view T is time for any time if you
view this one as a position this one is
velocity and this is acceleration you
could this would now give you the
position velocity and acceleration but
it's important to realize that these
vectors could represent anything of a
two dimensional nature